ma poi è già oppure è una sorpresa così
ha rovinate lo ospito e misteriosa chi
sarà mai loredana bertè possa il suo
telespalla bob non posto nessun altro
ciao amici allora oggi faremo questo
video molto particolare ringrazio
riccardo per essere venuto nel mio
studio
faremo un progetto molto importante ma
di questo non possiamo parlarne perché
un po come norma dell'area 51
nel frattempo registriamo questo vi darà
vita di oggi allora è una sfida nella
sfida è una cosa seria non è un gioco
no ci sarà anche un vincitore non lo so
spero di no facciamo che in che cosa
consiste bisogna pensare a un film
attorno a un film serio né una serie tv
e provare a in un minuto soltanto a far
capire all'altro di come si sta
trattando soltanto disegnano ok quindi
voi che sapete che io disegno da dio
se ho scelto un avversario decente cioè
che sia nel mio delle sue tappe del mio
calibro cercando ragazzi nominare anche
voi disegno che che facciamo e
soprattutto i miei questo è sempre
difficile indovinare miele faccio uno
semplice giusto che farà capire gli
conceda migliaia nel primo
aspetta già questo è meglio è il
disegnatore che come l'affare perché no
cavolo dai naruto naruto tema area 51
il problema è che tutti raffiguri
perfettamente nella testa cosa fare e
sai come farlo io no provare quello che
viene pietro allora se dovrei pensare
quindi va bene
sì ci siamo allora è già passato un
secondo mi mettera a ridere gol di
guarin un casino poi allora tu dimmi
quanto rapporto un iniziare dalle
orecchie quando fai ma guarda è un
mostro è un pokémon non posso dirti
niente come dirmi niente va bene
[Musica]
quattrocchi aspettare pikachu facendo la
cosa che ha indovinato coniato prima
però sapere e stai papig messi
io perfetto ecco il guerriero che
riuscirà a sconfiggere ma cv
[Musica]
sprigiona un'energia pazzesca ci sono
arrivati la fusione completata vi
perseguiteranno in questa cosa vuoi se
non impegna la domanda è cosa vuole lui
è bellissimo perché non so come fare la
coda seghettata quindi l'appello perché
non alle zampe non ha niente se tutto va
bene quanto finato prima credo devo dire
allora mette un po a via pio v
assolutamente dice stephen di universo
come può essere sparato dai dai
un castello con le gambe sì sì anche
cast mag nuovo no no no non ho mai visto
una no non hai visto
non lo so non ho testato con le gambe
quindi camelot alla ricerca dei moniti
di castelli avanti di sì ma non c'entro
niente capito ma le gambe 50 secondo il
castello con le gambe parti mamma mia
reazione è stato qui ha sudato era bello
complimenterò ho mai pensato la
concettuale rivaviva adesso questo è il
complicato
allora una pasta ai tranquillo sì quello
questo secondo per cortesia capire
niente è difficilissimo sembra un po
solo di vista
la casa di carta immaginazione mi ha
salvato questo va questo e questa cosa
qui bellissimo vedere come scusa ai
puristi perché gli occhi sono in
verticale sembra una rana e perché ora
voglio vedere cosa secondo me gli occhi
non so neanche il naso vabbè il naso
buchettino ma gli occhi vivere macale
che nella mia testa io non ho la memoria
fotografico in testa è una roba che non
è quella effettivamente non saprei fare
neanche guardato verso così va bene con
quella indovinato pensi che io cioè se
studiassi bisogno pensi che il primo
pensare in grado di fare male
secondo me no sto pensa di energetico
proprio materico ma non vedevi dai
suggerimenti per la guida il principe è
iniziato e napoli
no non dire queste cose che ho detto che
ho capito il mio dio è più secondi ma
cos'è il cane che animano la cosa l'etna
comics e tiene in mano la mia capacità
di disegno che non proprio a e signore
degli anelli aveva raccontato il signore
degli anelli da quest'anno 36 secondi si
facciano i capelli e un no bayern motivi
e questo è perché vi ho detto guarda
questo qua è salendo a esatto sta
salendo una persona che a questa persona
che tiene in mano un anello madonna
io ho fatto tutto sto giro così un
anello detto sicuramente va bene questo
monte fato quindi molto che è molto
carino allora so però è molto molto
molto easy lo faccio ma con la scritta
un proprio particolare vai vai sponge
bob no no
una tavoletta è un edificio in
condominio è un foglio di carta un
mattone una mattonella 4 nella nota
violetta bene ed i segni disegni la
faccia
no è una è una lapide di una persona
morta dieci comandamenti sempre dc come
mandamento gioco e contra come il
contrario
dai sospiri che spero possa scrivere il
titolo aspetti
l'esorcista no al contrario di dieci
comandamenti quasi che era un extra
dieci cose che potrei puoi fare ma puoi
anche decidere di no gli allenamenti e
bibbiano
sembra che sono più riporta mr di tomb
rider animale che non posso scrivere
quel numero è unanime dai in anime
cambiare il cielo è tatuato addosso da
cosa era il destino toschi redhat 91
dove c'è scritto death note l'altro dove
c'è scritto detto potrebbero col
linguaggio divisi ma tu pensi a le
proporzioni di un diario no ho capito ma
che è come se tu dici guarda ed etno e
inizia a fare così
questa è la penna e questo capito gli
serva comunque dai non è neanche così
male come pensa potevo fare molto di
peggio
ora c'è quello poi c'è scritto tengano
prova beh se poi c'è l'altro che se ne
può trovare che non esiste però c'erano
altri hanno gestito da shin gamelan
perché sennò quale capì subito un nuovo
devo eccolo elsa uguale italy per una
stessa grafia l'effetto lo so però
pochettino verifica fiducia non a s e lo
fa con esse non è una ypsilon
vabbè allora mi vado a ostacolare da
solo agrietour time spongebob
la casa blu la melevisione no giovanni
muciaccia l'ispettore gadget no
lupin iii open quarto trasformerà la
macchina ti facevo io i transformers
vado nuovo partito io sono perché sono
vediamo no scherzavo questi non so
neanche da dove cominciare da una linea
è un death note
no non sarà in altri di howl dare
salendo viene subito però poi quando a
finire aspetta quella la è un cavo
dell'elettricità rom che rubano iran
etica e camicia me nelle riuscirci plex
mentre c'è una perché c'è una porta
sopra è capito cos'è vero prevenivano di
capirlo
da allora posso dire qualora il concetto
esiste però sembra ti dico cosa sembra
aspetta allora guardate guardate
attentamente e la p4 tra attentamente
[Musica]
ricche more attacco nric ha così amici
no non è vero o no che potrebbe essere
quasi amici in effetti però non lo è
salmo come che altro cioè nel senso
forse lui gli ultimi dominatori delle
sedie a rotelle
no matrix è una ics è una signora
televisiva si si guardano guardalo lei
lui è che la pepe lato sulla sedia a
rotelle e piace alla xxl una ics e un
pelato che cos'è
ma lo vedo poco dopo ho capito spero che
vi sia piaciuto cimentatevi anche voi
con i disegni fateci sapere se volete
nostro video del genere sa che se fate
questo gioco voi fate vedere i disegni
su instagram con l'astag riccardo sa
disegnare fa vige in nome della roma lo
facciamo quindi spero che vi dice
piaciuto iscrivete anche una scatola
campanella che vi aggiorniamo sui video
che escono nuovi sono migliori la
notifica e noi come sempre cd vediamo
che d'istinto il comando il volo che
fuso della bella ragazza
[Musica]